in a rare set of interviews three former
presidents spoke about the life and
legacy of President George HW Bush Bill
Clinton Barack Obama and George W Bush
sat down with 60 minutes to share
personal experiences and informed
opinions of their colleague and in an
excerpt you didn't seal in last night's
broadcast the 43rd president also shared
a bit about his unique connection to the
41st president so much has been written
about George Herbert Walker Bush as a
president what was he like as a father
he was a great father and I if you were
to interview my brothers and sister to a
person we would say couldn't have a
better father and I think the reason why
they would say another reason why I'd
say it it's because he gave us
unconditional love and some of us tested
it I might add he was there was no doubt
about how much he loved us which I think
is a very important gift that a father
can give to his children it's been one
of the great joys of my life my
friendship with him our arguments were
good-natured and open and we continued
to debate things all the way up until
recently he was a good reminder that as
fiercely as we may fight on policy and
on issues that ultimately were Americans
first and that kind of attitude is
something that I think a lot of people
miss when you look back at your father's
term in office as president yeah he
starts to many people look better and
better yeah we all do that's the way
time works I think he's gonna go down as
the greatest one-term president ever
because of his foreign policy definitely
handling the end of the Cold War for
example reunification of Germany George
W Bush also told us what he learned from
his father about personal diplomacy
here's a here's a George Bush story one
of the things I learned from him was to
give these world leaders kind of special
treatment if possible and I said dad I
need a place to bring the lamrim Putin
would you mind if I brought him a
Kennedy buckboard knowing full well that
Pooh
was it wow this is really great and he
said not at all and he so Putin lands
and there's dad at the foot of the
stairs to greet him so he said you want
to go out in our boat and Putin said oh
I'd love to go and so Putin has this
interpreter that's kind of a you know I
didn't look at much of an outdoorsman
and the old man opens that thing up full
blast and this guy stand in excess
interpreters like white knuckles you
know hanging onto the boat wonder if
he's gonna live and he's cutting through
these waves it's just classic George
Bush what was Putin doing he loved it
you know Putin's kind of these macho
dudes that he salt spray coming across
you know and he thought it was wonderful
it's the interpreters
nerve-racked